Jag gillar att du ändå försöker introdera våran brand, sälja gymmetsrustning på nätet och att driva journalistik inom Impact.
Jag tror att det är ganska olika.
Det måste vara jättekomplexa grejer du jobbar med också.
Inte alls, inte alls.
Make Sweden Stronger.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger...
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Då säger vi välkommen till Kamilla Bergman till podden.
Hej, tack!
Tjena, tjena.
Detta är första gången vi lämnar träningsvärlden.
Jag har fått mycket på att inte bara fokusera på träningsbolag, även om det är där jag har min bas.
Nu ska vi börja gå in mot den mer allmänna ytan, och då är du den första gästen som ska tilltala alla människor.
Wow, vilken ära!
Känner du att du går hem i alla läger?
Nej, verkligen inte, men en ära.
Ja, gött.
För de som inte vet vem Camilla Bergman är, kan vi få någon sorts liten kort hispjuts eller intro, eller vad säger du till folk?
Ja, absolut.
Jag rör ju också till det lite för jag hette Camilla Björkman förut, som var ganska likt liksom, men jag är journalist i grunden och har rört mig i mediebranschen i 15 år typ.
Var tidigare chef för en tidningsmedie som heter Driva Eget.
Sedan har jag haft det i min egen tidning inom handlarkarbranschen.
Jag har varit inne och ut på olika mediehus och jobbat.
De senaste sex åren har jag varit på nyhetssiten BreakIt.
Där jag jobbade först med affärsutveckling och sedan tre år som vd.
Nu har jag startat mitt eget bolag som heter Loop.
Vår första nyhetstjänst heter Impact Loop.
Vi rapporterar om impactbolag.
Jag fattar att nu borde ju frågorna vara om Impact Loop och BreakIt och liknande som alla känner till, men tandläkartidningen, vad var det?
Det är rätt random.
Vad var det för någonting?
Det är väldigt udda.
Man kan väl säga att det jag gör nu, att bygga upp ett mediehus med olika nyhetsvertikaler där den första då är Impact Loop, jag hade den drömmen redan för...
Vad blev det nu?
Det är över tio år sedan i alla fall.
Jag håller inte riktigt koll.
Då kände du att tandläkaren var den där jävla, där ska du in och ja.
Det är lite så.
Det fanns en tidning till Salu på marknaden.
Det var en person som var dum eller smart nog att köpa den.
Det låter ju större än vad det är, det var ett varumärke, det var ingen personal, den hade inte kommit ut på något år heller.
Men då köpte jag det här inkromet till den talmakas Zinet, som den hette med Z och drev den.
Det var mycket Z på den här typen.
Och hade den i några år parallellt med frilansade, jag har jobbat mycket som frilansjournalist och skrivit en bok om hur man lyckas som frilansjournalist.
Jag har alltid haft det här att driva eget på något sätt som min usp ihop med journalistiken.
För att göra en lång historia kort så insåg jag efter att jag hade tagit ett lån och köpt den här tidningen för 200.000, vilket var fruktansvärt mycket pengar för mig på den tiden, så insåg jag att jag inte kan något om tandläkare, att jag inte är särskilt intresserad av det, att jag inte kan börja, att det inte finns intäkter, att tidningar inte har kommit ut på ett år, att jag inte har skribenter.
Så det var bara att sätta igång.
För jag hade absolut inte råd att förlora de där pengarna.
Och jag hittade en gammal tandläkare som kunde skriva gratis och en annan frilans.
Det var verkligen att lära sig att bygga en lönsam tidning från grunden.
För jag gjorde liksom allt.
Skrev, fotade, sålde annonser, förhandlade med tryckerier och det var jättelärorikt.
Och sen lyckades jag faktiskt, vilket är helt sjukt, men lyckades sälja den.
Inte så jättemycket pengar men det blev en vinst några år senare.
Och det är jag väldigt glad för.
Det är ju skitcoolt.
Det är ju faktiskt jättehäftigt.
Ja, konsthistorier dock men ja.
Jag tror inte ens de är på din LinkedIn.
Jag kikar ändå på det lite.
Ja, den borde de ha med.
Det är Jaspalje.
Jag är faktiskt jättestolt över den.
Jag tror jag bara loppar bort och lägger till det.
Det är inget jag mörker i alla fall.
Jag tänker att Break It känner väl folk till och Driva Eget känner väl i alla fall alla som har startat mindre företag till.
Det är en klassisk tidning där.
Men den här Impact Loop som du driver nu, det är relativt nytt, även om många följer.
Du är väldigt öppen med dina resor och så där, men kan du inte beskriva lite Impact Loop, lite mer vad det faktiskt är?
Det är en nyhetssajt och ett nyhetsbrev kanske framför allt, som kommer ut varje dag där vi skriver, vi gör journalistik som håller ledare, entreprenörer och investerare i loopen kring allt som händer inom Impact.
Impact är ett väldigt brett och flummigt begrepp egentligen, men vår definition är att det är bolag som jobbar mot ett eller flera av FNs hållbarhetsmål.
Så man har det som sin viktigaste, vad ska man säga, som sin affärsidé helt enkelt.
Det får inte bara vara att man gör lite gott eller att man har någon klimat kompensera lite, utan man ska ha det som tjänan i sin affär.
Målgruppen är, nu har vi ungefär 5 000 prenumeranter på nyhetsbrevet och av dem är det några hundra som är betalande.
Så ser vår affärsmodell ut.
Men de är alltifrån, de flesta är entreprenörer inom Impact, men det är också många investerare och lite ekosystemet runt Impact.
Så man kan väl säga att vi är väl som en som en break it fast inom Impact och Klimatech.
Och sen har vi, jag ska ändå inte riktigt säga att vi är det för att vi är lite annan totalitet.
Men jag har liksom lärt mig att det är ganska bra att ändå dra en parallell till något som folk vet om.
För då blir det lite tydligare.
Är det svårt att inte fastna, eftersom du ändå var på break it i flera år, är det svårt att inte fastna i samma arbetssätt eller samma tänk eller samma beteende?
Jättespårt.
Och till stor del är det ju en nytta.
För jag lärde mig ju så sjukt mycket under den perioden.
Det var ju verkligen, jag kom in, efter att break it hade funnits i typ ett och ett halvt år tror jag.
Och då var vi bara en liten grupp, handfull människor.
Och sen att ta alla de stegen upp till att vara ett välkänt journalistiskt varumärke och en affär.
Det var ju jättemycket bra som jag nu tar med mig.
Men nackdelen är att man går lätt.
Särskilt när vi sätter rubriker och skriver.
Då får jag verkligen säga till mig själv, när det här blir för mycket break it, eller för mycket DJ också kan det vara, eller för mycket sifted, eller vad det nu är som är en europeisk sajt.
Och jobba på att hitta sin egen ton.
Och det är inte alltid lätt faktiskt.
Man vet ju också vad som funkar på något sätt.
Ja, jag fattar det.
Varför gick du till...
Frågan är inte varför du lämnar break it, utan frågan är snarare varför valde du att starta eget istället för att vara kvar inom ett bolag där du ändå var ganska etablerad.
Du var ju redan vd där och många kände dig på den resan och jag gissar att du fick ganska mycket uppskattning i...
Du var ju ganska öppen i, så här ska jag driva break it, här är hur jag jobbar med det här.
Det är ganska ovanligt att en vd beter sig på det sättet, så det är ganska roligt att följa från sidlinjen.
Men varför välja att starta någonting eget eller någonting nytt?
Ja, det är en fråga som har många svar.
Jag märker hur jag svarar annorlunda på den ända sedan jag lämnade.
För jag slutade på Breaker för ett och ett halvt år sedan nu.
Jag har varit med i lite olika poddintervjuer och jag får ju frågan fortfarande från många av sådär.
Beroende på var jag är någonstans i livet så är det som att jag svarar på ett nytt sätt.
Vi är helt skitsoprent liksom.
Men om jag ska försöka sammanfatta så det var liksom en kombination av att jag hade varit där i sex år och jag var en liten delägare.
Jag hade kunnat ta ett lån från en av de andra aktieägarna och köpa in mig i break it.
Så jag ägde nästan 4-5 procent i bolaget.
Eller varje liten beroende på var vi tog in pengar och så här.
Så på ett sätt kände jag verkligen att jag är med och driver det här bolaget och verkligen som vd och jag har fulla mandat och frihet och så där.
Men det var ändå inte riktigt mitt bolag till syvende och sist.
För att det fanns två grundare som också var största ägare som jobbade i bolaget som journalister.
Och jag har alltid haft det här.
Jag har drivit mitt eget företag från och till ända sen jag gick på journalistlinjen.
Och alltid känts det att jag vill vara entreprenör.
Det är det jag klarar inte av att vara anställd.
Jag blir för obstinat för det liksom.
Och jag var väldigt tydlig med grundarna Stefan och Olle när vi drog igång.
Att ska vi göra det här, då vill jag verkligen att vi tre som kör och sådär.
Men hur mycket man än säger så, så tror jag att när det väl kommer till kritan, om man ska ta beslut om en massa grejer, så är ju ändå största ägarna som bestämmer.
Och jag märkte hur det där blev ett större och större problem för mig.
Och i kombination med att det är ganska utmanande att vara vd i ett bolag där grundarna jobbar kvar och framförallt men att ha mycket åsikter om saker och så där.
Det har vi också skrivit, eller i alla fall jag är en av dem, ganska öppet om på Break It.
Vi kunde ha ganska mycket dustar och det blev med ganska mycket dustar.
Det var jobbigt till slut, det var inte bara roligt, det skrev vi om med ganska mycket humor men det var också jobbigt.
Och så kulminerade väl allt i att jag gick på föräldraledighet för jag fick mitt andra barn.
Och i samma veva så höll vi på i en process med Bonnier som skulle köpa upp Break-it och köpt in sig på 30 procent.
Det var så många komponenter som till slut sammanföll att jag kände att nu är rätt timing och tagit livet eget igen.
Men då var det lite såhär, vad 17 ska göra?
Det var inte så att jag hade sett ett brinnande behov och det här måste jag bara lösa med mitt bolag.
Utan jag var lite vilsen och höll på att sväva runt.
Men det var i alla fall story.
Jag fattar, jag fattar.
Jag kan förstå precis.
Jag har ju inga delägare i gymkompaniiet men ibland när den diskussionen kommer och tals, även om det är människor jag verkligen tycker om, så kan jag känna att den situationen kommer uppstå.
Jag kommer alltid vara grundare och alltid se bolaget som mitt.
Och även om jag hade velat bjuda in någon och de ska få ha mer bestämmande rätt, så kommer det aldrig riktigt bli så för att man kommer alltid på något sätt landa i att det man själv så kör.
Så jag tror att det är jättesvårt om man inte är med precis från start.
Det är faktiskt grymt att du har den insikten, för jag tror att det är väldigt många grundare som är vd som också tänker efter några år att nu ska jag ta in en vd som verkligen ska bli som en delägare och det kommer att funka jättebra.
Man är lite naiv tror jag i det.
Absolut.
Vi ska inte fastna i min resa, vi ska fastna om dig.
Någonstans landar du ändå här i att starta ett nytt, ni kallar det för mediahus men mediebolag eller vad ni vill ta.
Det är ju inte den smidigaste affärsidéen som någonsin har funnits och speciellt inte nu med allt möjligt.
Varför valde du att starta ett ny journalistisk satsning och tänkte du på riktigt att det här kommer att bli bra?
Ja men det tänkte jag.
Jag var inne på lite olika affärsidéer och så men sen kände jag att jag brinner.
Kan du inte säga någon annan affärsidé du var inne på?
Ja men det var så himla konstiga.
Det var verkligen jättemärg.
Jag tycker det är jättekul med trädgård till exempel.
Så hade jag någon idé om att, vi pratade att jag hade den här idén en dag.
Antingen måste man hyra in en grävskopa, eller så måste man gräva, eller så måste man stå med skopan själv.
Det finns liksom inget mellanting, så då skulle jag kolla på någon innovation där.
Ja men nej.
Det var bra att du lämnade.
Jag landade faktiskt väldigt snabbt i att det är journalistik jag ska hålla på med, för det är det jag kan.
Jag tror mycket på det, man ska gräva där man står.
Om man har gjort någonting, men jag har ändå gjort det här nu i snart 15 år.
Jag vet peppar peppar vad som krävs för att bygga en journalistisk produkt.
Men jag måste erkänna, jag fick ett lite wake up call när jag läste ditt LinkedIn-inlägg igår, där du skrev såhär att många tror att de har svaret på...
Ja, du kan ju säga själv vad det var du skrev för lyssnarna.
Ja nej, jag har ingen aning.
Jag glömmer allting så fort jag skriver.
Jag har ingen aning.
Ja men många tror att de har receptet på liksom framför och dom är fastna i det typ och så var det verkligen för mig.
Jag trodde typ att jag kan precis allt om att bygga ett mediehus, men sen har jag ju insett nu Milopa, men det kan jag ju absolut inte.
Men när jag drog igång som svar på din fråga så trodde jag ändå att det här kan jag så bra.
Jag gör så att jag bara copy paste på vad jag gjort tidigare så kommer det att bli ännu snabbare nu.
Det är väl en av mina styrkor och svagheter.
Jag är ju lite naiv.
Jag tror typ att det flesta...
Det är klart det kommer att funka.
Annars får jag väl tänka om lite så.
Det är ju både bra och dåligt.
Två frågor där, jag tänker...
Hur funkar du när...
Det är en hel sidofråga, men...
När du skriver...
Jag funkar nämligen så att jag går in i det och försvinner i någon sorts...
Zoom-grej och när jag uttryder så kommer jag inte ens ihåg vad jag har gjort nästan.
Och sen är det bara...
Men kan du gå och tänka på vad du har skrivit eller vad du...
Fan, jag borde ha skrivit den här formuleringen.
Jo, jag kommer nog ihåg det mesta jag ändå har skrivit faktiskt.
Ja okej, det är imponerande och lite jobbigt.
Jag kommer kanske inte ihåg rad för rad men det är också för att jag jobbar med journalistik.
Det är en ganska bra kunskap att ha för om man skriver en artikel kan man liksom...
Som vi skrev för Inke Klubb, jag har skrivit en artikel, lalala.
Men vad var egentligen frågan?
Om jag skriver saker i affekt, vilket jag ibland kan göra lite halvaffekten.
Jag skrev en grej på internationella kvinnodagen om att jag tyckte att internationella kvinnodagen hade blivit en dag då vi medelklasskvinnor kan berätta om hur bra vi är och hur viktigt det är med kvinnor i börsbolagsstyrelser och sådär.
Det finns massa kvinnor som inte ens...
Det är inte det viktigaste för mig att det är jämställt till börsbolagsstyrelser, även om det är jätteviktigt.
Gud det här blir så lång utläggning nu, men kort och gott.
Men i efterhand så kunde jag känna lite att det är väl bra att man gräver när man står och om man nu brinner för börsbolagsstyrelser och jämställdhet så skriv om det då.
Man måste inte skriva om kvinnor i ett afrikanskt land som är ojämställda om man inte känner att man har koll på det.
Men ja, det är bra att skriva lite affekt också.
Ja, jag tycker alltid man skriver bättre affekt.
Ja men det är härligt att höra.
Men den andra frågan på detta var helt annorlunda då.
Men när du väl hade bestämt dig för att nu ska jag starta någonting inom det här journalistiska, när du kom, för jag gissar att då gick du först och främst till de här människorna som verkligen litar på dig eller som tror på dig, som du tänker att de här kan investera.
Såg du hur de suckade lite?
Liksom blev det sånt, fan, var du tvungen att starta något inom det här?
Eller kände de också direkt bara att ja, men det här kan bli riktigt bra liksom?
Ja, men alltså faktum är, för de som jag kände, det är några stycken som har gått in lite mer.
Till exempel, du nämnde Drivaeget då som jag jobbat för och Anders Andersson som grundade Drivaeget, han har investerat en miljon då i Loop.
Det var min första investering i företaget.
Han och sedan några till sådana här liksom, som har gjort det, alltså media entreprenörer som har gjort det förr och så har de tjänat lite pengar på media och vill gärna investera som affärsänglar, men det är ju ingen som är då så dum i huvudet att de startar ett nytt mediehus, förutom jag.
Så det var snarare så att, pam, äntligen kommer någon här efter alla dessa år.
Och så är det en bransch de kan och förstår och kan verkligen brotta in sig och så de tyckte bara att det var kul.
Och sen var det absolut, jag sprang på, det var ju lika många sedan då när jag började mer pitcha kallt, typ som tyckte att, vad är journalistik, om det ens har finnas, det är ju AI och the better return on investment på SaaS-bolag.
Vilket jag tycker är en himla konstigt argument för det beror väl på, det kan man väl inte säga, det beror väl på...
Ja det är som att säga, starta inga restauranger, inga märken, ingenting, för att det finns bara en bransch som är...
Ja, det är jättemärkligt.
Ja, verkligen.
Nej, jag köper inte alls det argumentet.
Men däremot undrar jag varför ni valde Impact som...
Nu vet jag att du är lite...
Du säger att du skriver i affekt och sånt där, men det kan ju också märkas att du är engagerad i en viss sorts frågor.
Du väljer kanske dina områden, då märker man ju att här lever du upp lite och går upp i affekt.
Men tänkte du att Impact, är det någonting som du tycker om eller är det någonting där du faktiskt tror att det här är en startpunkt för bolaget, där bolaget faktiskt kan tjäna pengar och komma igång?
Jo, men egentligen både och.
Det är väl en lärdom som jag har tagit med mig från åren som gått.
Det är bra att tänka att rikta sig business to business.
Det finns väldigt många i journalistik som vill rikta sig till privatpersoner, eller skriva bred nyhetsrapportering.
Men det är jättesvårt skulle jag säga.
Mycket bättre att ringa in en ganska nischad målgrupp där man kan ta fakturan på bolaget.
Man kan se en affärsnytta.
Då var jag inne på lite olika nischer.
Till exempel mjukvarupolag var jag en sån som jag var ganska långt gången i.
Dels kände jag att det låg lite för nära Break It som skriver mycket.
Jag hade själv varit med och byggt upp hela SAS-området på Break It.
Då kom det in det här med passionen också.
Man ska göra något som man brinner för, inte tillbaka i tandläkarebranschen, utan något som är viktigt.
Och också något som är viktigt.
Jag tycker att man ska göra något som lämnar världen på ett bättre ställe.
När alla de här komponenterna, när jag hade den listan, då blev det väldigt tydligt att impact var rätt.
Men jag ska säga, det var verkligen inte så många som tyckte att det var en bra nisch att börja med.
Jag fick ganska mycket säga att det är så brett och luddigt och impact kan ju vara allt från social hållbarhet till klimatet och vad betyder det egentligen och sådär.
Men när jag väl satte ner foten och då ringde jag till Erik Englaup som är vd på Norsjön Launcher som är riskkapitalbolag inom impact och typ så här frågade honom, ska jag göra eller inte, som att han skulle bestämma.
Men det var typ det som behövdes för då var han så här, nej men det är bara bra att det är brett, det behöver ju ändå många personer som kan betala.
Det är hett då på uppgång, ja men kör så här.
Då var det okej, då kör vi.
Då visade det sig, det här var lite mer än ett år sedan, men det visade sig vara också jätterätt i tiden.
Jag fattade ju att det var på uppgång, jag fattade nog inte hur mycket det var på uppgång.
Nu känner jag ju bara, kik jag har slagit jackpot typ tio gånger om att jag har det hetaste området i media.
Det är kanske jag som tror det, jag känner inte så.
Det är väl detta och AI som är modeorden just nu, eller det som man verkligen, det är det det handlar om just nu.
Ja verkligen, och det visste jag faktiskt inte då, så det blev en jackpot helt enkelt.
Hur länge tror du att ni kommer att stanna i, för tanken från början har ju varit att göra flera sådana här loops, hur mycket krävs för att man ska gå vidare till nästa loop så att säga?
Ja nu vill jag ju vara så öppen och transparent och bara säga att vi är där nästa på gång.
Och det är, men nu faktiskt, jag är verkligen ledsen Joel, men svaret på din fråga är, vi ska dra igång nästa loop rätt snart.
Men vilken den är kan jag inte säga, för jag måste liksom förankra det med några och också faktiskt vara ut och sälja lite på den loopen.
För det är ju vår tanke att det är alltid mycket lättare att sälja skinnet innan man skjuter björnen.
Så vi behöver vara ut och prata med några partners som kan backa det här finansiellt.
Och då vill inte jag att det är utöver hela staden.
De ska känna sig lika...
Ja men vad spännande.
Ja.
Okej, ja vad kul.
Men kommer, du får säga när jag grottar för mycket, men kommer liksom, kommer du vara ansvarig för varje loop?
Eller letar ni nya, hur många loopar kan man rodda som en person?
Ja, men det är en jättebra fråga.
Och jag, svar att det är väl helst inte jag, men...
Men det är ju, ja det är jättesvårt.
I början kommer det antagligen vara du, jag förstår.
Nu har jag ändå två personer, Krishan och Johan, som roddar Impact Club väldigt bra och där Johan är lite mer ansvarig.
Så jag ska inte släppa Impact Club, det kommer jag aldrig göra, men jag kan ändå frigöra lite mer tid att jobba med nästa.
Men sen, det här är ju typ det svåraste i vår bransch skulle jag säga.
Alla har väl sina utmaningar, jag vet inte hur det är i din, men att hitta personer som ska starta upp en helt, även om vi har vårt process, så är det ändå så här, det här måste vara en person som kan starta upp en ny loop, som brinner för ämnet, som kan typ leda andra personer inom det.
Det är, allt och allt vet jag inte riktigt hur det ska gå till.
Om jag ska vara...
Ja, jag gillar att du ändå försöker inkludera vår bransch, er bransch, genom att sälja gymutrustning på nätet och att driva journalistik inom Impact.
Jag tror att det är ganska olika projekt.
Ja, det är måste vara svårt att hitta folk.
Eller är det så att det inte är bra?
Nej, alla har jobbat med det.
Nej men det är kanske inte riktigt samma komplexitet att hitta någon som ska sälja gymgolv som att välja ut ett visst specifikt antal kunder och hur man skriver och man hittar etiska kompasser mellan vad man ska...
Jag bara tror inte att vi ligger på riktigt samma nivå där.
Vi har nog lite lättare.
Men det är skönt att bli inkluderad i det här.
Det måste vara jättekomplexa grejer du jobbar med också.
Ah gud nu sitter vi här och bara...
Inte alls.
Jag tänker, när ni jobbar med...
För du beskrev det lite som ett nyhetsbrev och lite som att ni binder ihop människor i den här impactsektorn eller människor som vill investera med bolag som satsar och sådant.
Jag är rätt intresserad av hur ni själva gör bedömningen där när företagen är på något sätt era kunder och investerarna blir på något sätt era kunder men ni ska ändå skriva granskande om både bolagen och investerarna kanske.
Det måste finnas en intressekonflikt där och det måste finnas en del svårigheter med hur man kanske vinklar en artikel eller vad man ska ta med och inte...
Är det något ni tänker på?
Är det klart ni tänker på det men hur tänker ni kring det?
Ja nej men det är en jätte jättebra fråga och jag har...
Jag tror att...
Och faktum är att jag fattade nog inte hur svårt det skulle vara innan vi drog igång för att de...
Om man tar Breakit till exempel, så där drev jag visserligen och vi drev mycket att Breakit ska vara ett community och vi kyrkan i byn och i techbranschen och vi hade olika nätverk och så det var mycket också communitybyggande.
Men där, ju större vi blev där så blev det också tydligare att här är redaktionen som är lite mer frånkopplad eller vad man ska säga från communitybyggandet.
Jag vet inte om det låter flugligt men...
Jag fattar, jag tror att man fattar.
Man måste liksom lite stänga av den kanske då för att kunna skriva ganska tuffa grejer och granska på det sättet.
Och att det är ju svårare när man är då ett community också som vi är och vi har nätverksträffar och vi träffar de här personerna, det är inte hur många som helst.
Det är ju som jag sa, vi har fem tusen prenumeranter på nyhetsbrevet varav några hundra är betalande.
Vi vet ju precis vilka de är liksom.
Och man träffar någon ena dagen och så skriver man om den nästa dag.
Och jag har valt att liksom ta det angreppssättet att vi är som en lokaltidning.
Alltså vi är som en liten, som tidningen är en liten typ ort.
Att då måste de journalisterna och den chefföretagen måste ändå kunna gå på typ en middag med någon och ha trevligt och vara professionell i det.
Men sedan också kunna, eller vad säger jag, vara personlig i det.
Men sedan också kunna nästa dag granska den här personen och vara professionell i sitt jobb.
Annars kan man inte vara journalist.
Då blir man liksom en någon sorts PR-person typ.
Och sedan är det inte så lätt såklart, men jag tror man får bara se till att fixa det, annars kan man inte göra det här.
Ja, jag tänker att för er del kanske det är, även om det kan vara lite såhär halvluddigt, så kanske det som journalist går att hitta den gränsdragningen.
Men kan era kunder och läsare hitta det företaget som ni då går och äter med eller pratar med, är de lika förstående?
Eller har ni haft några såhär jobbiga, när de har såklart inga outa företag, men kan du uppleva att kunderna ibland har varit irriterade?
Jo, absolut.
Vi ser att ni har gjort något rätt ibland.
Jag har haft många sådana diskussioner, och gladligen, jag tycker det är roligt.
Alltså det är verkligen så.
Hittills har alla förstått när jag har antingen ringt eller tagit på mejl eller linked in eller så där, att vi måste kunna skriva om någonting negativt också.
Det kan inte bara vara att vi höjer företaget i skyarna hela tiden.
Och vi är journalister och måste kunna vara oberoende i det och så där.
Alla fixar det.
Men sen så...
Jag tänker också att man kan göra det här till något positivt.
För jag tror att många människor är lite rädda för media och känner att media är ibland lite avkopplade, nej inte avkopplade, bortkopplade från diskussionen.
Man är inte med och diskuterar på LinkedIn eller kommer ut och träffar folk fysiskt i verkligheten.
Det är mer och mer blivit att många journalister sitter på redaktionen och skriver saker som andra kan säga jag känner inte igen mig i den där bilden, ni har inte varit här, ni har inte sett hur hårt vi jobbar eller att vi visst har hand om våra anställda.
Hur kan ni skriva att vi tio pers har hoppat av vårt bolag när det är helt odramatiskt, vi är jättebra kompisar med dem.
Det är massor av sådana här situationer.
Då tänker jag att det är bra om man i stället kan känna med Impact Club, att man känner oss och vi är i verkligheten hela tiden.
Det finns typ en psykologisk trygghet, det bygger på ett ömsesidigt förtroende.
Man ska lita på oss och känna att vi lyssnar och är ut och tar saker på allvar.
Men det betyder inte att vi stryker alla medtörs, absolut inte.
Vi ger och tar.
Det förstår jag och tänker.
Jag fattar.
Kan du uppleva att du blir för personligt kopplad till bordet?
Du är som sagt jätteöppen.
Du har gjort, jag tror du kallar det för vd-resan, och du gjorde den här 100 dagar med Break It.
Man får väl följa dig både när du pitchar till investerare och när det går bra och dåligt och allt sånt här.
Men du pratar också om att vi ska ha dialogen med Impact Loop och med företagen och sånt där.
Finns det en risk i att du som person blir nästan det stora ansiktet för Impact Loop, så om man inte tycker om dig så tycker man inte om Impact Loop och ifall man anser att du sa någonting någon gång så blir det liksom för mycket kopplat till tidningen.
Vad finns riskerna och fördelarna där?
Jo, men absolut så är det ju.
Men jag har tänkt lite som att jag har ändå apropå gräva där man står så jag har ändå först jobbade det jag då med Anders Anderssons på Driva Eget det var exakt samma sak, han startade Driva Eget och var så ansiktet utåt och drev upp hela det.
Och sen började ändå efter några år så började ändå varumärket mer leva sitt eget liv liksom och vi kom in, jag kom in, vi kom in andra personer och då blev det som att Anders blev inte riktigt, hans varumärke blev inte riktigt bärande för hela tidningen.
Och samma sak med Stefan och Olle som startade Break It, jag tror att idag så är det ändå många som känner till Break It som inte nödvändigtvis har en relation med Stefan eller Olle eller med mig när jag, det begav sig eller med Jon som nu är cheffaktör, att man har ändå, det är liksom efter några år så man kan använda det personliga varumärket i några år för att skapa bass och dragkraft och så där och då tror jag ändå att fördelarna överväger nackdelarna såvida man liksom inte hamnar i något drev eller säger någonting helt urbotad dumt.
Men efter några år måste man tänka att nu måste du komma in i lite andra profiler.
Kommer du vilja lämna över till andra profiler att fronta ditt varumärke?
Ja alltså 100 procent, jättegärna.
Men det är också svårt för att många är så kopplade till i Sverige, någon är kanske jättekopplad till Dagens Industri.
Ska den då gå in och plötsligt ta sig en vårt varumärke?
Det bästa är ju ofta att man hittar folk som är lite okända och så jobbar man upp dem och bygger dem.
Hade du velat ha en Camilla-kopia då eller hade du velat ha någonting som var helt annorlunda?
Alltså, man ska ju säga nu att nej jag vill ha någon som är helt olika mig men det är ju alltid skönare när det är någon som vill lika.
Men svaret är väl såhär att nej, mycket heller någon som är olik mig.
Men tyvärr så blir det ju ofta så att man ändå letar efter folk som är lika ännu och det där måste man ju tänka på för det har jag gått i väldigt många gånger att göra fel där.
Men jag har ju till exempel, jag kan ta ett exempel, vår CMO Diana som jag också jobbade med på Break-It.
Så hon och jag och några till byggde upp den kommersiella avdelningen på Break-It.
Nu är hon och min andra kollega Melina, han går till ett annat ställe emellan så jag har inte tagit dem därifrån.
Men vi är jätteolika på massa plan och det är så bra för att vi kompletterar varandra jättebra.
Jag är liksom en rörig virrpanna, hon är sjukt uppstyrd och det hade inte funkat annars liksom.
De här investerarna, du nämnde Anders här men ni har väl ett gäng investerare och du beskrev lite att de tycker att det är lite kul att hoppa på resan, nästan som att de har längtat lite grann eftersom du ändå har varit delaktig och sett ganska många investerare från olika håll investera i många och kanske även rapporterat om det.
Skulle du säga att de som investerar i mediebranschen är mer...
De gör det mer av en såhär, det här ska bli roligt, vi ska hitta på någonting, vi vill synas eller höras eller vi vill tro på någonting mer än att det är business.
Eller är de här människorna lika mycket business?
Det var en jättebra fråga.
Nej men jag tror faktiskt att det är lite som du först sa.
Alltså att man har mycket hjärta till journalistiken, man har gjort det hela sitt liv.
Det är en bonus om det blir en jättebra affär.
Sen skulle jag säga att det är ingen som vill bara hälla in pengar och man vill ju ändå ha en bra return on investment.
Men då, man kanske inte förväntar sig gånger 50 pengarna, utan snarare lyckas vi göra gånger 5 eller till och med gånger 10 pengarna.
Då är det jättebra.
Men jag vill ju verkligen att vi ska bli ett jätte framgångsrikt bolag och bygga nästa stora mediehus i Europa.
Inte liksom vara ett litet, nåt som man gör bara för att välja ett projekt, absolut inte.
Och det tror jag att vi inte kommer kunna göra om vi bara tjattar på här nu.
Ja, jag fattar.
Vad ligger liksom business caset i detta?
Du nämnde att det är mer företagskunder som är intressanta kanske, eller det är i alla fall där pengarna finns kanske.
Men hur mycket tänkte du kring ekonomin när du startade?
Och stämmer det med hur det ser ut idag?
Man brukar ju säga att allt har dubbelt så lång tid och kostar dubbelt så mycket som man trodde.
Ungefär så har det varit.
Men business caset som jag ändå fortfarande jobbar efter, det är att 2028 ska vi omsätta 20 miljoner på generationer, återkommande intäkter och ungefär lika mycket på partnerskap.
Så det är ju då typ större företag som vill använda våra kanaler för att marknadsföra sig.
Lite som en banneraffär, fast vi gör det på ett mycket bättre sätt.
Och då omsätta 40 miljoner, det kanske inte låter super mycket men det är mycket för att vara med i det jag skulle säga av den första åren, sen ska vi ju bli mycket större.
Men det var det business case jag sålde in till investerarna.
Och då räknade jag ändå att kan vi omsätta 40 miljoner varav hälften i återkommande intäkter och vi har en bra vinst på det, då kan det vara värt.
Man sitter ju alltid och spekulerar, men jag skulle säga minst 100 miljoner är ett sådant företag värt.
Om man tittar på vad andra värderas i samma kaliber.
Då var det en bra affär för de investerarna, för de gick in på en värdering till 13,5 miljoner.
Så då har vi ändå gjort en fin affär, men vi är absolut inte där än.
Det är väl så hypotetiskt.
Jag älskar ändå att dela med er lite siffror.
Folk ska alltid vara så känsliga med att snacka siffror, det spelar ju ingen roll.
Nej verkligen, jag håller med.
Men nu i år kommer vi nog att ligga någonstans mellan 4-5 miljoner.
Vi kommer inte att gå med vinst på helår, men vi blir lönsamma framåt vinterkanten.
Bra jobbat, det är väl inte så illa att vinka på det.
Det är rätt fort jobbat måste man väl säga.
Jag tycker också det.
Sen får man komma ihåg att vi ändå har kostat då.
Jag tog in 6 miljoner så jag har ändå kostat lite pengar.
Men jag är nöjd skulle jag säga.
Eller aldrig nöjd men ändå nöjd.
Hur många kollegor är ni idag?
Vi är fem totalt.
Hur tänker man kring kollegor i den här branschen?
För det är ju inte riktigt en fast arbetsuppgift de ska göra.
Utan den måste ju vara ganska passionsdriven.
En passionerad arbetare inom detta måste jobba femton gånger bättre än en opassionerad.
Och samtidigt så kan det ju bli väl mycket åsikter eller väl mycket känslor i detta.
Så hur tänker man när man tar in folk och hur håller man dem motiverade samtidigt som man hittar ett bra ramverk?
Jag skulle säga att det har varit det svåraste, alltså utan tvekan.
Mycket svårare än det här med att bygga ett team helt från grunden.
Mycket svårare än att nå product market fit, som det heter, att hitta för att sälja och göra journalistik.
Det är typ det citat enkla.
Men det svåra har varit att få ihop ett helt nytt team.
Och det har jag inte lyckats med eftersom vi var sex personer.
Av dem från början, av dem är tre nu, ut ur bilden, och två nya har kommit in.
Så hårdvinklat, eller nej det är inte hårdvinklat, halva bolaget är borta, nya in.
Så hade jag bara satt den rubriken om jag hade skrivit den som journalist.
Och jag tror att det svåra, om man tänker såhär, rollerna var ganska straightforward för mig.
Att vi behöver vara typ tre stycken som jobbar med journalistiken.
Jag och två till.
Man måste vara ett litet team och en redaktion som kan sitta och bolla saker.
Man tar olika puckar.
Det är väldigt svårt att vara själv.
Jag var inte så sugen på det heller att sitta själv och bara skriva.
Inte efter att ändå ha gjort några resor.
Men sen hade jag lite tur att jag sprang på mina tidigare kollegor från Breakit, Emeline och Diana, som var på ett annat företag.
Vi började prata och jag insåg att jag kanske har en chans att få över dem också nu.
Diana är marknad och är svinnduktig på allt från köptannonsering till byggaregister till grafiska.
Det måste verkligen vara ganska många likheter till din bransch.
Hon är så mångsidig i det och kan göra allt det där.
Så där känner jag att hon måste in om jag har chansen.
Samma sak med Melina som är fantastisk relationsmänniska, jätteduktig på att skapa och sätta affärer och hålla i kunder.
Då menar jag de här mer partnerskapen som vi också finansierar oss med.
Jag hade egentligen inte tänkt börja med så många, men det blev så ändå bara för att jag hade lite tur.
Men sen då, ja, man kommer in på det negativa, så har det ju varit svårt att...
Det har liksom inte funkat med det teamet, utan två personer har slutat från redaktionen.
Det är liksom ingen dramatik med det, det är mer bara att, vilja göra någonting annat, och det här startuplivet kanske inte riktigt var det som de ville göra.
Och det, tror jag verkligen är jättebra insikt, för det är alldeles för många som tror att de vill jobba på startup, men sen när det väl kommer till kritan så vill de inte det.
Så jag har all respekt för det verkligen.
Upplever du att du har satt en känsla för att det är det här som gäller på Impact Group, eller är det snarare att du och de här två tidigare kollegorna går in i gamla arbetssätt som fungerade för er tre, och så får folk haka på det?
Är detta en ny vision eller är det liksom en fortsättning på vad som fungerade för er, och så får folk gå in därinne?
Det är en jättebra fråga, jag tror faktiskt att du har rätt i det, och jag tänkte på det bara häromdagen, att vi kanske inte är så himla sammansvetsade eftersom vi jobbade ihop under många år, vi har redan gått igenom alla de här, du vet, som krävs för att bygga ett starkt team, att man ska forming, storming, norming, performing i faserna, vi vet allt om varandra, vi har byggt upp var arbetssätt, jag tror att det är en liten chock att komma in i det faktiskt.
Men jag har insett verkligen att det är ju bra också för att det har ju uppenbarligen funkat, men det får inte bli för mycket så heller, utan vi måste också hitta vår egen grej.
Och jag tycker att vi har gjort det också faktiskt, det måste jag verkligen säga.
Men det jag skulle säga var att jag tror att det svåra är just för oss att hitta personer som både är duktiga journalister eller duktiga vad man nu jobbar med, men också gillar Impact som område som är ganska nytt, så det är inte så många som har jobbat med det.
Och business to business vill skriva för företagsledare snarare.
De flesta journalister vill ju jobba på DN eller Svenskan eller Aftonbladet och jobba med krim eller brevjournalistik.
Och dessutom, till råga på allt, så ska man gilla att jobba i ett litet bolag där man bara är några stycken och man träffar typ inga andra.
Man sitter bara, vi är ju ett superlite team och det ska funka.
Alltså det är så himla många grejer som ska funka.
Jag vet inte, jag har inte svaret på hur man fixar det faktiskt.
Om fem år.
Ja, jag tror lite såhär, typ Chrisan som är en av de här fem, han är också frilans, han är konsult för oss och har kört sitt eget race i tio år eller ännu mer, så han är van vid det.
Johan kommer från en liten organisation.
Det har nog varit bra tror jag.
Jag tänker att vi ska ta ett par frågor till så ska vi runda av snart.
Du är väl på semester tror jag.
Ni kanske inte har semester, ni körs om.
Jag är lite intresserad av när man är journalist eller vad du nu kallar dig för någonting.
Mediahusägare säger det så till folk.
Jag brukar inte säga att jag är journalist, jag gillar att säga det.
Blir man cynisk i sin approach till människor?
Jag tänker alltid när folk kontaktar dig så är det alltid någonting de vill.
Det måste alltid finnas en vinkel i vad man vill få ut av det.
Tänker du på det?
Nej, nej faktiskt inte.
Du har ju helt rätt i det, men nej jag tänker inte.
Du menar att du tänker att alla människor går på gatan och folk hejar snällt, frågar om man ska med på en lunch, kanske man ska, nej för så ser det inte ut för de andra ni.
Alltså jag är märkligt nog så att det är, ja, bra, jättebra fråga.
Jag tänker typ att det är lite så folk kanske ännu, det är väl alltid så att man har någon sorts, jag har nog aldrig tänkt att folk bara kontaktar mig för att de vill just träffa Camilla, människan Camilla, för jag är så himla kopplad till mitt jobb, det är väl lite sorglig insikt om jag ska dra det till sin spets, men jag blir så förvånad om de bara hej du verkar vara en jättetrevlig person, jag vill ha ingen aning vad du gör, jag vill jättegärna träffa dig.
Du är bara såhär, men fan är jag, hur vet du det typ, att jag är en trevlig person, det låter ju jättesorgligt när jag säger det.
Jag fattar precis, man blir ju kopplad till sin yrkesroll såklart, och speciellt i sådana yrken där yrket är så genomdrivande.
Okej, det var ju lässant.
Det kan ni tänka på ni som vill, för att du är journalist.
Jag hoppas på det där.
Jag är lite nyfiken också på, när du startade Impact Group, så gissningsvis då eftersom du pitchade, så hade du någon sorts budget och du hade någon sorts actionplan, och nu nämnde du att det hade tagit dubbelt så lång tid, och det kostade dubbelt så mycket.
Men har det liksom gått så som du tänkte från start, eller hur mycket har ni avvikit, hur mycket pivots har det varit i det tysta, och har du följt liksom grunden?
Jag kan säga att just också för att jag har gjort det här så himla många år, så vi har inte avvikit så himla mycket från planen vad gäller affärsmodell.
Nej eller i ärligt talat, vi har inte avvikit så mycket alls.
Utan jag kollade faktiskt på pitchen här, som jag satt ihop för ett och ett halvt år sedan, och det är ju nästan ordagrant det vi håller på med, nischad journalistik, och till och med att jag hade satt priser på abonnemang som vunnit.
Men den stora avvikelsen och som jag inte trodde skulle hända var väl just det här att, svårigheten med att sätta teamet.
Jag tänkte nog att alla som hoppade på från start, vi kommer att köra det här nu fem år typ.
Och så var det ju inte riktigt.
Det är spännande, det är alltid människor som är svårast.
Alla företag alltid.
Camilla, jag är jätte, jätte, jätte tacksam för att du tog dig tid.
Väldigt spännande att få höra om en så annorlunda bransch.
Som du säger, det finns ju inte så många sådana här företag som startar upp.
Jag hoppas att folk lyssnar och tar med sig någonting.
Jag är jätte tacksam att jag fick vara med.
Tack för grymma frågor.
Kul det ska bli att lyssna på det här sen.
Tack själv.
För jag funkar nämligen så att jag går in i det och så försvinner jag i någon sorts zoomgrej och sen när jag är utrydde så kommer jag inte ens ihåg vad jag har gjort nästan.
Och sen ser ni bara.